NATO leaders have this week been meeting
in London to mark the 70th anniversary
of an organization that styles itself as
the most successful military alliance in
history
however provocative claims from French
president Emmanuel macron that NATO is
as he put it brain-dead triggered an
angry reaction from others not least
from US president Donald Trump who
described the comment as nasty insulting
and disrespectful Verve half-angle
America as usual work to seek some sort
of compromise and consensus concluding
that it had been a very successful
meeting so our question here on to the
point is NATO at 70 brain-dead or
fighting fit
[Music]
[Music]
well thanks so much for joining us here
on the onto the point here in the studio
in Berlin and I'm joined by three
excellent journalists beginning with my
Deutsche Welle colleague Emmanuel
showers who's a French born political
correspondent and in a manual says
gloves off macros brain dead comments on
NATO put diplomacy at risk also with us
Vladimir se pop from the Russian desk
here at DW he believes that NATO is the
perfect enemy for Russia if NATO didn't
exist then for domestic purposes the
Kremlin would have to invent it and very
warm welcome to to Martha looming he's
an author and senior editor at the
Berlin based a leader Targa Spiegel and
he argues that NATO is still the
strongest military alliance in the world
the infighting at the London summit
shows just how complex many security
challenges have become mutter I would
like to begin with you ahead of the
London gathering one UK newspaper The
Guardian newspaper said the meeting had
the potential to be and I'm quoting the
birthday party from hell there were
certainly fears that things could get
very ugly so now that the dust has
settled is is NATO more united or less
United than before I think it is more
United than before it because we saw
some surprises with strong commitment
from the US president Donald Trump to
NATO strongly rejecting all braindead
comments by the French president no
pulling out from erawan no obstruction
from from any other participant that was
fear about so there were in fights and
struggles yes but I think the unity in
the alliance has been strengthened the
unity it's interesting their mouth so
there the German headlines that I was
looking at earlier said that after the
summit closed there had been no upper or
no disaster no bus stop it all sounds
pretty poultry for an organization that
as we say sees itself as the as the
greatest military alliance in history
you're right it is a defensive position
saying there was no I mean split up of
all these but
but giving but giving the the the
different kind of threats were facing
starting from Russia to China cyber
world all these things you name it it
was not supposed to be a meeting it's
not even called a summit it's called a
meeting with no clear-cut agenda anyway
so it was not supposed to to solve these
problems or get a unanimous position
about new threats and things like this
even though they found a final pamphlet
about topics they agreed upon vigorously
I think there was some sort of an agenda
during that meeting there was a set of
decisions that people had agreed upon
before even the meeting the defense and
foreign ministers had agreed upon
certain things that in the outcome was
that London declaration that was made at
the summit I think that was important
for them to meet at this occasion of the
70th anniversary to reiterate and
reassess as well this dis Alliance hmm
and while all that was going on there
was a very interested what you might
call role reversal between presidents
Trump and Mac Rome with McConnell
lashing out at at NATO and Donald Trump
saying that NATO that he's a fan of the
NATO alliance and that NATO has come a
long way in the last three years what do
you make of all that well that's a bit
rich coming from charm to actually blast
someone over very sensitive comments I
would say but also French pride huh
pride because I also don't necessarily
agree with the way a man um back row
actually addressed NATO I think I get
the point that he wants things to be
shifting within the Alliance and that's
that's fair enough I think it needs some
shifting but calling it a brand ed at
such a sensitive time where we're having
so many geopolitical issues I think
that's not necessarily the right way to
go and also it also goes on to show that
he's resorting to strategies that our
president term strategies he says he has
achieved a lot we using this blunt
language he's adopting trans trade
strategies
actually when Donald Trump actually
shook shook up NATO last year it
resulted in countries to actually put
more money into their defense politics
so maybe it needs some kind of shaken up
I'm just not sure that not using the not
using diplomacy to achieve so is very
wise given the current political
situation globally mm-hmm Vladimir
Vladimir supporter what are people in
Russia likely to have thought or to
think what would their emotional
reaction be to seeing NATO celebrating
its 70th anniversary there was much talk
about celebration in the Russian state
media if you look or what Russian media
covering from from London it's very
cynical comments about not being busy
with itself about states of the chief of
the state's presidents and prime
ministers gossiping about each other so
watch what taken together all this about
that it was the first topic and the
second one was not all liking money to
compete with the beautiful Russian
rocket systems and with the new
beautiful Russian weapon systems so
basically it's quite cynical views in
Russia frightened of NATO in the way
that people in Europe are frightened of
Russia not at all I mean Russia is so
proud and lists on its military right
today is this new Russian film appearing
on the Russians cinemas about another
one Battle of the second world war in
Russia which is a huge production which
is supporting the Russian national pride
and the military history again so there
is no such thing that is the Russian
being frightened and I think the
Russians know that NATO is not a
connecting and conquering and
imperialistic power so they know the
difference between the Unruh no one
really cares if you talk to the normal
average people in Moscow in Sanders book
I mean no one really cares not all this
danger from Rada is instrumental
instrumental is a it to realistic
political goals for a consolidation of
society for some domestic issues but
it's not such fear in the broad
population like
in Europe but it was interesting
nevertheless to hear Vladimir Putin
talking from Sochi from the Black Sea
resorts talking about NATO's continued
expansion as he put it and then
nevertheless saying that he hoped that a
shared interest in common security would
prevail is that mother a first step
perhaps in a new direction some people
are hoping that it is a dialogue a
different kind of dialogue a different
kind of conversation I think it's very
very difficult I mean my calm it raised
the topic of new relationships with
Russia but I'm I'm afraid it won't
happen very soon
they're just too many developments I
mean still the annexation of the Crimea
and the war is still going on in in in
east of Ukraine we will have the
Normandy meeting on Monday coming up in
Paris we will see if that leads to
something but we have the news being
viewed as Allah must test for possible
new relations and yeah I mean you know
but given the really what we get
progress on Ukraine but given the recent
scandal in Berlin with the with the
likelihood that the Russians are
involved explain the recent scandal for
our viewers a man was killed in Berlin
and tear garden supposedly and many
indices point to that with the
involvement of the Russian Secret
Service the the perpetrator was called
but he's silent about it and two
diplomats were expelled in Germany so
there are huge tensions right now how is
that likely to impact the Ukraine
meeting on Monday this coming Monday it
will impact the meeting in terms of is
this the right time to make new kind of
policy towards Vladimir Putin and I
think no German politician right now can
say yes it is the right time okay but
still I'm given Urkel going to Paris to
meet well you know which and who knows
how the think will turn out they will
know it and I hope and I hope there will
be some concrete steps towards
de-escalation in the eastern Ukraine any
hope is in the Russian I I cannot I
don't know what's happened in Paris next
week but
yes yes okay the escalation is to crane
yes things like that but no new I mean
strategic partnership in any kind of
there's no talks about new strategic
partnership towards Russia and this
talks about country de-escalation step
Normandy format amount Minsk agreement
with the escalation in the eastern
Ukraine and I hope there will be
concrete steps in this direction okay
the debate about NATO's goals and
purpose goes back a long way right to
the very beginning in fact but so far
nobody has described the Alliance's
braindead and there's little debating
the fact that militarily NATO is a force
to be reckoned with
last year the North Atlantic Treaty
Organization flexed its muscles in
Norway it was the biggest military
exercise since the dissolution of the
Soviet Union and a show of resolve
directed at Russia before the summit
French president Immanuel McComb made it
clear that he desired an end to the
confrontation with Moscow and a new
definition of NATO's aims who is our
common enemy what are our common topics
this question deserves clarification
even as you see it's a very strategic
question sometimes I hear is Russia our
enemy is it China is it the mission of
the transatlantic alliance to designate
them as enemies I don't believe so our
common enemy within the Alliance is the
Terrorism that has hit every one of our
countries with that president McCraw had
set the direction of the NATO summit and
rebuffed Alliance partners especially in
Eastern Europe in addition he criticized
more severely than any other so far the
unilateral American withdrawal from
Syria and the actions of NATO partner
Turkey in the region has macron driven a
wedge into NATO
it's an interesting question Emanuel is
president Makran putting the future
cohesion of NATO at stake at risk
he certainly you know he's arguing that
it's all very good spending a lot of
money on the military it's all very good
having boots on the ground and being
efficient militarily but you need to
have strategic goals and the central
strategic goals we just saw was that is
the question who is the enemy what's the
answer well here are we so very
diplomatic Emmanuel macron saying that
we don't have enemies we need to
actually negotiate with them and do not
come and not consider them as enemies
it's all very good but also we see that
29 countries form NATO and they all have
diverging interests in terms of defence
most of them don't spend enough
according to NATO regulation on the
defence budget so yes then there needs
to be a new strategy there also needs to
be an identifying of the actual threats
we have new zones of conflicts that are
to be identified currently the threat at
the moment the threat is not necessarily
one country or another the threat is
much more global this year for well at
this meeting
NATO acknowledged that China was posing
new opportunities but also new
challenges with its rise and of course
the situation with Russia at the moment
poses a threat when it comes to melding
with elections fátima will probably be
able to say more about it than the me
Emmanuel macron just outlines the fact
that we need a new strategy for NATO and
that's what I was saying earlier black
by just saying that the organization is
brain dead is not going to bring things
much further mmm who is the enemy
what is if the enemy is not the country
what is if the enemy is climate change
or a globalization on global poverty not
mentioned of the the gathering in London
as far as I can tell
climate change what is if the enemy
cannot be fined with weapons what if the
enemy is operating on the level of a
mass media of fake news of manipulation
of the public opinion is the latter
like Russia now what has the natter
right answers to these dangers coming
from not from the country not only on
the convenient way with pen sir with
pants with it Thanks it's all stop and
convenient weapons let's go back back in
history a little bit I mean we had to
bipolar world the Cold War there was a
clear-cut enemy and there was Soviet
Union and it's gone after the wall came
down there was a term coined in the Cold
War called flexible response it was how
to react in kind of war towards Soviet
Union troops if you have a flexible
response you need a flexible response
today about new threats there is no
single biggest threat but that doesn't
mean that there are not multi-part polar
threats as for example Russia or China
or cyber war or terrorism from within
that NATO members don't necessarily all
share the same values as they did for so
long they don't necessarily share the
values that are mapped out in the
preamble of the NATO treaty yes but do
they have to share the same values to
confront the the the variety of threats
maybe not maybe they can confront the
variety of threats with different kind
of values I mean clear clear example is
retro type Aguila and the president of
Turkey who clearly has different kind of
values than the rest of NATO before we
continue I'd like to come back to you
once know mr. arrow and let's just go to
a clip that we have of the the the the
the way that President Edwyn addressed
the meeting in London the agenda the
very robust agenda he brought with him
that some people have dismissed as black
mayor let's listen if our friends at
NATO do not recognize as a terrorist
organization those against whom we are
carrying out our fight against terrorism
then excuse me we will oppose any step
that NATO seeks to undertake
welted we were talking about shared
values or values that are not
necessarily shared your newspaper the
targa Spiegel writes Turkey regularly
behaves as if it couldn't care less
about the shared values and interests
that underpin the Alliance yes but it
still might be a valued member of the
Alliance even though we have the dispute
about the s400
defense system a Russian defense system
we have disputes about Syria about about
the cooperation with Russia in that
region about supporting Islamists in
Syria and so on and so on not to not to
talk about everything that is inside
there Turkey which gets reason for for a
lot of worries so but it still is is a
very valuable member of the Alliance and
the South flank is valuable because they
all have an equal say in the matter so
there's no country that is less than
than the other and that's I think that's
one of the things that make still makes
NATO valuable people are worried about
Turkey and the course is now on summer
saying Turkey should not be a member of
NATO yes but it is still and this
meeting in London I think there was much
to say about conflicts of interests and
conflicts of personality personality
clashing with so Emmanuel macron talking
with Justin Trudeau from Canada and that
gave a bit of the feeling of a black
schoolyard and I'm not sure the world at
the moment deserves that kind of
attitude from him I would like to get
back to the point you mentioned about
the past was another because the whole
set of the problems are the holes
dangerous sources of danger shifted
completely in recent debates decades it
is not a turkey became the member of the
matter the danger was completely
different than now and now it's Middle
East as the hot spot of the world
politics so Turkey plays it completely
different role in the process and this
is what we are talking about
whole world is changing so quick and so
far and so fast that we need to react or
not on it to react very quick to this
and the question is is not able to react
that quick to the new dangerous that's
like I could remind you about the there
is the 30 30 30 initiative and I think
it's very valuable
I might explore it a little bit it means
we have NATO has to be able in 30 days
to have 30 battalions 30 ships and 30
air wings in every corner on the earth
so if they if they work on this
initiatives I think it's very well
valuable and it might confront a lot of
threats they are facing mm-hmm I think
we are so facing new threats for example
the cyberspace and NATO has to become
performant in fighting that this is a
new place of conflict that is actually
the actual space and it also has to
develop tools in in that regard I think
that threats have diversified and if
NATO wants to survive it actually has to
find a way to address those energy if I
make state up to Facebook groups from
st. Petersburg from st. Petersburg TRO
fabricant to push ideas via Facebook to
the American public and keep fighting
through these Facebook groups American
public one part of the American public
against another part of American public
but can ships and tanks do against this
equation let's talk just for a second
because I would like to and I want to
hear what Emanuel has to say about one
point that we haven't touched so far
there's a lot of tension in NATO ranks
about money a significant number of NATO
members according to Donald Trump a
freeloading including Germany
we will pay for 4.3 percent of the
largest GDP ever nobody's ever had a GDP
like we have right now and nobody's to
come close and other people were paying
1% some people paying less than 1% of
they first of all GB it's not fair and I
think
but it's not fair with your French
background
do you understand Germany's reluctance
to to meet spending targets well it has
a history as well because of World War
two Germany was reluctant for a long
time to allow military spending at all
and this side of history is still very
very present in every decision made in
like regarding to a result of what
you're saying is that there are French
troops on the ground fighting al-qaeda
fighting is was my second that was my
second point actually so Germany spends
way less than France in its defense and
France is actually paying the price of
blood in Africa in order to protect the
rest of Europe that is a fact and indeed
that is problematic it is also
problematic in the partnership between
France and Germany because they agreed
no later than in October they did agree
to spend less on a coordinating
coordinated defense system but Germany
the German parliament is is waiting is
spending too much time discussing the
budgets rather than putting the money
where it should be and that actually
hinders the French German relationship
as well Faramir what's your response to
this this deep streak of pacifism that
still is very central in German politics
military politics and life if I talk to
my Russian friends visiting visiting San
Petersburg Moscow if I tell them what
German media writing and covering about
the condition of the Bundeswehr no one
believes me troops into the field
without without weaponry Italy coasters
yes or little submarines basically
nothing unimaginable for people living
in Russia for a country like Germany
having this kind of army yes I'd say
Germany should spend more they should
spend more not necessarily on hardware
even though I think the the army has to
be modernized
very very much but they should spend
more on cyber defense this is one of the
huge topics you have NATO countries have
to face as a security threat and to
develop and and build up the need the
needed skills for cyber defence is
something that is really really
important and I think you might even get
a majority of Germans committed to that
not necessarily to defense spending the
traditional way but let me add one more
point to to President US President
Ronald Trump's claim I mean you still
have to see the United States spent like
five trillion dollars from 9/11 to now
on the war on terror all over the world
so the huge defense budget of the United
States goes to many places in the world
not just to European defense this is
another one point which no one in Russia
really understands about Germany this
high-speed Internet connection if you
talk about cyber attacks and cyber
defense no one really can imagine that
the country like Germany can have such a
bad quality of Internet but there will
always be a discrepancy between the
American army and the German or European
army in the making for example because
we simply do not share the same vision
of the of the world simply said I mean
Germany because of history will never be
a country which will want to expand
which you want to intervene with its
army but at least it should have a
functioning army and the fact that
regularly angle America cannot fly
somewhere because the plane wouldn't
take off or something like that that
that that goes on to show shame yes it
is a crying shame and it's not just
Merkel it's the president as well it's
the foreign minister and and and many
other because just planes don't fly and
I think this is for a country like I
agree with quite a lot of this and I
think not just Russians are laughing
about this but the rest of the world is
doing that as well well especially the
Russians and the Chinese who are
developing a terrestrial army and
canario flirt but if we come to the
Chinese I mean China was made
so little time and so there you overlap
a new threat in cyber war with territory
traditional threats and it's called who
or why the the firm that makes up the
five G system and that is supposed to do
it in Germany we've got a wrap-up the
most successful military alliance in
history was the claim ever justified is
it Hooper's or is it a fact thank you
very very much for joining us here on to
the point today brain-dead or fighting
fit NATO at seventeen that's been the
question we've been addressing I hope we
given you plenty of food for thought if
we have come back next week until then
bye-bye and just
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you